Triberg im Schwarzwald:
ein idealer Ausgangspunkt, um im Wald zu
wandern und die schöne Natur zu genießen.
Besonders eindrucksvoll: eine
der weltgrößten Kuckucksuhren.
Wer Lust auf Süßes hat, ist
im Café Adler gut aufgehoben.
Hier gibt es feinste Konfiserien
und unter den vielen Kuchen
auch die Königin des Schwarzwaldes,
die Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte:
für Konditormeisterin Dagmar Holzer
im Sortiment unverzichtbar.
Wenn vier Personen oder
eine Familie am Tisch sitzen,
bestellen drei Schwarzwälder
Kirschtorte und einer was anderes.
Also von dem her ist das
sehr bedeutend für uns.
Für den Biskuitboden benötigt man 180
Gramm Mehl, rund 80 Gramm Speisestärke,
40 Gramm Kakaopulver, etwas zermahlene
Vanille und einen Spritzer Zitronensaft.
Außerdem: fünf 5 Eier,
die getrennt werden.
Das schaumig geschlagene Eiweiß süßt die
Konditorin mit 200 Gramm Zucker.
Dann hebt sie das verquirlte
Eigelb unter das Eiweiß
und gibt anschließend die Mehl-Kakao
-Mischung dazu.
Alles gut verrühren.
Jetzt werd‘ ich die vorgefertigte, schön
melierte Masse in unseren Ring füllen,
dann wandert unser Biskuitboden in
den Ofen bei 180 Grad, circa 20 Minuten.
Für die Kirschfüllung werden
eingemachte Sauerkirschen mit Kirschsaft,
Zucker und Stärke aufgekocht.
Den fertigen Biskuitboden
schneidet Dagmar Holzer
in eine dicke und zwei dünne Scheiben.
Dann geb ich jetzt die Kirschen,
unsere Sauerkirschen,
in die Mitte des Bodens und
verteile sie vorsichtig mit der Palette.
In die steif geschlagene Sahne
kommt ein gutes Schnapsglas
hochprozentiges Kirschwasser.
Diese Schicht kommt direkt auf die
Kirschen und wird gleichmäßig
bis zum Rand des Kuchens verteilt.
So, und dann geben wir den
ersten Boden dazu, drücken ihn leicht an.
Auch der Boden wird gut
mit Kirschwasser getränkt,
denn für Dagmar Holzer ist der
Alkoholgeschmack wichtig.
Über die nächste Sahnedecke
kommt der dritte und letzte Boden.
Jetzt kann die Form abgenommen werden.
Der gesamte Kuchen wird nun
auch an den Seiten mit Sahne bestrichen
und mit Rosetten und
Schokoraspeln verziert.
Das ist gehobelte Zartbitterschokolade,
die gebe ich jetzt oben in der Mitte drauf
So, da sin[d] wir jetzt fast fertig mit
unserer Schwarzwälder Kirschtorte.
Jetzt kommt noch das letzte I-Tüpfelchen:
die allerletzte Sauerkirsche obendrauf.
Auch wenn die Schwarzwälder
Kirschtorte als Kalorienbombe gilt,
so gehört sie für viele zu einem Ausflug
in den Schwarzwald einfach dazu.